over the past month we have laid out
many of the ways that college is failing
American students and their parents and
the government in our society more
broadly every year it costs far more to
go to college than it did in the
previous generation those costs are
rising far faster than inflation most
students need tens or even hundreds of
thousand dollars in loans to go to
college and yet what they learn there is
not impressive the classes themselves
are teaching less than ever
unless it's extremist political ideology
but even if college is failing most
students feel they have no choice but to
go there just aren't options some people
are working assiduously to change that
Isaac Morehouse is the founder and CEO
of praxis it's the startup that promotes
apprenticeships as alternatives to
college degrees and he joins us now
Isaac thanks for coming on having me
here this is a tough pitch we spent the
last month working on this and talking
to a lot of people go to college and
looking at it from all angles and one
thing you hear from almost everyone
who's in college we're planning to go is
that I know it's too expensive and I
know I'm not gonna learn much and there
are other downsides but I don't have a
choice
so how do you make the pitch to sort of
high aptitude middle-class kids you
could go to a four-year college what do
you tell them to convince them not to
yeah and those are exactly the type of
people that we work with look the good
news is the degree is dead I'm not
overstating that it is a myth that you
need a degree to start a career now
unless you want to be a doctor or a
lawyer or heaven forbid a bureaucrat or
a professor you don't need a degree and
the best and brightest are realizing
this and they're getting started in
their career now and if you're sitting
in the classroom you're not giving
yourself in if you're gonna get left
behind frankly so you know I we can
point to the the hundreds of people that
we've worked with and we've placed them
in apprenticeships and they've gone on
to get great jobs many of those jobs by
the way if you just look at a job
posting they will say degree required
but it's actually not true employers
just want to know that you're gonna
create value for them and there are so
many ways that you can prove that better
than just that dead piece of paper one
of the things employers want is an
assurance that someone has vetted you
and that you're smart and that you kind
of
your act together the you have high
aptitude but also the capacity for
achievement without a degree how do you
convince some of that yeah you know it's
funny that you mentioned that a friend
of mine who is a CEO I just saw a tweet
of his recently he did a little poll and
he said this is not scientific but this
is a very much in line with the hundreds
of CEOs and hiring managers I've talked
with he said would you if you only knew
this about someone who would you rather
hire someone who'd run a marathon or
someone with a degree 85% said the
person who would run a marathon that's
just one example but that's one of those
things that you know it signals a lot of
things at once so look you can go out
and create projects and say hey I built
this I did this you can start offering
to do some projects do some work for
free you can go and build up kind of a
portfolio that showcases some of your
skills and interests figure out what are
you interested in build some actual
skills and start working on things and
if you just think about for a minute
zoom out if you were to enroll in
college in the fall three years from now
you'd still be in the classroom if
you're going to go and this fall and do
something like praxis or something where
you're going out you're getting some
work experience you're building a body
of work in three years you're gonna have
three years of professional experience
under your bank you're gonna have so
much more to leverage into a great a
great job a great career that's
absolutely right and there's a huge
lobby of people whose job it is to lie
to you and convince you otherwise but it
is a lie so in the minute we have left
give us the pitch for practice I'm an
eighteen year old a decent grades fine
scores I could get into a solid four
year college instead I go to practices
and what happens then yeah so we're all
about launching careers and if you don't
want that if you want a debt fueled
drinking party that your parents will be
proud of go to college by all means if
you want to launch your career you're
going to need more than that you're
gonna have to quit playing around and
get out and do some real work and we
have a bootcamp a professional boot camp
where we've put you through just really
identifying your skills and doing real
projects and things as I mentioned to
kind of signal to prove hey I built this
I can do this and then we place you with
startups where you're doing it paid
six-month apprenticeship on-site and
you're learning from entrepreneurs and
you walk away at the end of the end of
the program almost all of our grants
ninety six percent of them get a
full-time job at the end so I'm
that's what we do at practice and I
think it's just the beginning of this
revolution man I want to force my kids
to do that Isaac thank you it's great to
see thanks for everything and truly I
hope that you and others offer an
alternative to a system that is broken
and collapsing in my view so absolutely
a job